what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the latest events
in the boku no hero story including what
could be the end
of the epic heroes versus villains super
fight that has been taking place for the
past
dozens of chapters are the villains
really about to retreat
or is this yet another misdirection
before toga and the others make their
final move
let's talk about it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content on this channel
please leave a like
and comment it really does help you
might think it doesn't matter but liking
and commenting on this video directly
supports
our channel because it tells youtube to
recommend this video to more people and
if you're new to anime uproar or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar finally this
video will contain
boku no hero manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
starts off with a panel
showing the shield hero crust giving a
thumbs up
just as he did mere moments before his
death
at the hands of shigaraki's decay the
next few panels show
aizawa miruko gran torino ryukyu and the
other heroes who have been
injured during the epic battle of jakku
we also see hawks mount lady and
others from the villain mansion along
with deku and everyone else who
contributed in some way to this
incredible struggle
against the villains best genius
proclaims that all of these individuals
who sacrificed their bodies
and in some cases their very lives
contributed in their own important way
to finally bringing gigantomachia down
the sleeping agent that momo had created
is now
finally taking effect and everyone who
fought against machia
up to this point did their part they all
helped to buy
time and to wear the monster down just
enough
for the sleeping agent to finally take
hold
this entire hero operation was a massive
team effort that so many heroes and hero
students participated in
and genust has faith that the heroes can
defeat the villains
right here and now meanwhile meteo is
helping to take down the nomu
including one nomu that appears to have
the exact same quirk abilities
as the shield hero crust this was very
interesting to me and i can't be the
only one that noticed it because
crust died just recently in the story
and then we get to see his face
in the very first panel of this chapter
and now we see a nomu that seems to have
a very similar power
to his power i'm not sure if this is
supposed to be some sort of hint about
crust and
this nomu or it's just a coincidence but
we'll have to wait and see
now i have to take back what i said
about bakugo's new hero name
in my previous pokuno hero video the
unofficial translation called him the
god of destruction
dynamite which i thought was fine but
not as cool as
lord explosion murder however the
official translation for bakugou's new
hero name
is actually great explosion murder god
dynamite yes seriously
i have to take back what i said because
this new name is even crazier and even
more hilarious than
lord explosion murder so i fully support
bakugo on this one
great explosion murder god dynamite is
freaking hilarious
and pretty awesome and come on it
definitely fits his
edgelord personality perfectly anyway
now that makia has been subdued best
genius and the other heroes can finally
turn their attention to shigaraki
and the league of villains mr compress
is aware that the villains are in big
trouble
with makia down and the rest of the
villains tied up and immobilized by
genius cables
there isn't much that they can do and
since shigaraki seems to have lost
consciousness again
compress decides that it's time for him
to act
it's now up to him to go from being a
side character
to a main character i mean definitely
not
but i do appreciate compresses wishful
thinking
compress knows that the villains still
haven't achieved their goals and they
still haven't achieved
their dreams so he doesn't want to let
it all end
here compress loves the league it was
the only group that truly accepted
people like him deviants with a dark
past
and outcasts were hated by the rest of
society
so compressed decides that he must
sacrifice his own body
to save his fellow villains he uses his
powers of compression
to carve out a piece of his own backside
and this allows him to wiggle out of the
cables that were tying him down
he then compresses spinner and shigaraki
into marbles and attempts to make his
escape
genius warns compressed that the butt
injury that he just caused himself
will be fatal if he tries to run away
presumably he will die
from butt loss i mean blood loss okay i
joke but seriously though
compress didn't just take out a little
piece of his butt cheek he actually
sliced off a huge chunk of his body
and he may have seriously damaged some
vital organs so yeah mr compress
may be dying as we speak compressed then
reveals that he is actually the
descendant
of oji harima the peerless thief
harima was a villain who stole from the
greedy heroes
and redistributed their wealth to the
people so he was some sort of
anti-hero robin hood type figure we
don't really know anything else about
harima or his quirk
but oji harima was actually mentioned
once before
in chapter 171 gentle mentioned
oji harima as one of the three most
infamous
japanese villains in history harimam was
mentioned along with
all for one and destro as all of this is
happening
dabi and shoto are still fighting but
since endeavour has apparently passed
out from his injuries
dobby decides that he doesn't want to
kill shoto
and not because they're brothers and
dobby is coming to his senses no
it's because he wants endeavor to
actually see shoto die
with his own two eyes man dobby
is so messed up and completely obsessed
with endeavor
dobby's entire freaking life seems to
revolve around getting revenge on
endeavor
and no matter what endeavor did to him
as a child i honestly wouldn't wish such
an obsessive hate-filled existence to
anyone dobby's descent into absolute
madness
is kind of depressing when you think
about it but let's move on
dobby uses a massive flash fire fist jet
burn
on shoto and shoto collapses to the
ground
dabi then joins up with mr compress as
compressed decides that he will leave
the rectification that oji hanima wanted
to bring about
in the hands of shigaraki and from this
it is clear
that compress is planning to forfeit his
own life in order to allow the other
league of villains members to escape
as compress finally ditches his mask and
reveals his face to the world for the
first time
we also see the full extent of his
self-inflicted injuries
and it's hard to imagine that compressed
can survive this unless you get some
top-notch medical assistance
right away but getting to an ambulance
isn't what mr compress
is planning to do as meteo rushes at the
villains
compress promises to put on a
once-in-a-lifetime
show an escape trick of epic
proportions and that is how this chapter
ends
this chapter really seemed to be
implying that the big battle is coming
to an
end and that the villains are about to
retreat
and it was also implying that mr
compress just sacrificed his own life
in order to allow his fellow league of
villains members to escape but is this
really
it are the villains about to flee the
battlefield and is this epic war arc
coming to a close it's possible but
personally
i don't think so not yet yes the
villains are in bad shape right now
including the big boss shigaraki but hey
the heroes are in bad shape too endeavor
deku shoto bakugo and many many other
heroes
are out for the count the injuries that
they have sustained
during this battle have caught up to
them and they are nowhere near
100 percent and yes the heroes have an
advantage because genus and meteos still
seem to be
in good fighting shape but all it would
take to change the situation
on the ground is one more major play
by the villains and speaking of which
where is
toga we haven't seen her ever since she
left ochoko to meet up with the villains
again
and of course we know that with her
awakened quirk
toga is able to potentially cause a lot
of damage to the heroes
especially if she consumed some of
twice's blood
at some point in the past which could
technically allow her to unleash
sad man's parade personally i really
don't think that this battle is going to
end without
toga doing anything not after all of
that build up about her quirk awakening
compress probably will end up
sacrificing his own life to rescue the
other villains and buy them some time
but i do think that the villains still
have an ace
in the hole and that ace's name is
toga but let me know what you guys think
are the villains really about to retreat
and give the w to the heroes
or is yet another major twist coming
is mr compress about to die for real
and is toga going to make a move before
this battle comes to an end don't forget
to share your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more boku no hero content right here
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or you
just haven't subscribed yet make this
the video do you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all it's annoying but unless you do that
you're still going to miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works feel free to
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata the world
a quiet respect liam thompson pate
heffer
ruthean yx emperor otaku thomas jones
spidey life canal
big buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari and finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica califon
alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokami and water their
red-haired raven
florian joy and garcia jack watches
anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these legendary
people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you